[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
آلة جميلة لها نقاء
ووضوح العالم السماوي ، فهي ليست
من الأرض بالطريقة التي
يمكن أن تكون فيها الآلة الخشبية ذات
إمكانات كبيرة في الجليد كمواد صوتية
[موسيقى
]  الاسم هو تيم لين هارت وأنا
مؤسس موسيقى الجليد وموسيقى الجليد هي
الموسيقى التي نصنعها في أوركسترا
آلات الجليد هذه ، جاءت الفكرة لأول
مرة منذ حوالي 21 عامًا كنت نحاتًا على الجليد
لسنوات عديدة قررت
أحد منحوتاتي  أرغب في بناء
كمان عملاق وكان لدي صديق
كان يصنع القيثارات وقد طرح السؤال للتو ،
أتساءل كيف سيبدو هذا الصوت
وقد ابتلع هذا السؤال الكثير
من بقية حياتي ، فالآلات
مصنوعة من اللون الأبيض  الثلج عبارة عن مزيج من
الثلج والماء مملوء
برقائق ثلجية وفقاعات هواء
وكلها أشياء مختلفة تجري
لصنع آلة واحدة من الكمان أو
الفيولا هنا ، ويستغرق جزء الجليد حوالي خمسة
أو ستة أيام يمكنني على الأرجح  بناء
أوركسترا كاملة هنا في حوالي سبعة أو
ثمانية أسابيع ، لدينا كمان كمان ، تشيللو ،
جيتار باس ، مندولين
، طبل بانجوس ، إكسيليفون
[موسيقى]
موسيقى الجليد ليست مجرد موسيقى كلاسيكية أو
موسيقى تجريبية ، إنها مجموعة متنوعة
من الأشياء المختلفة
هذا الشتاء سنضعها في حوالي 45
الحفلات الموسيقية لقاعة الحفلات الموسيقية تصميم محدد ،
إنه كهف جليدي عملاق واحد ، الكوخ الإسكاني في
الوقت الحالي هو عشر درجات فهرنهايت ، إنها
بالتأكيد مشكلة في موسيقى الجليد أن
أصابع الناس تجعل الناس باردين يلعبون
بمجموعة متنوعة من أنواع مختلفة من
القفازات.
درجة الحرارة هي أنك تعرف الشيء
الذي أحتاجه حقًا لجعل الموسيقى الجليدية
تعمل حتى لا يتمكن الكثير من الناس من لف
عقولهم حول قطعة من الجليد
تصدر صوتًا أو صوتًا جميلًا عندما
يأتون إلى قاعة حفلات الجليد
وهم فقط
مفاجأة سارة جدًا وتصدر نوعًا حقيقيًا
من النشوة للناس ثم
إنها مذهلة ، إنها
[موسيقى]